comme elle j'ai été une petite fille aux
ailes brisées mais j'ai réussi à prendre
mon envol
je ne suis pas ici aujourd'hui pour vous
dire quoi faire comment le pourrais-je
je ne suis pas vous mais à travers mon
histoire mon parcours je souhaite
simplement partager en toute humilité ce
que c'est que le pouvoir de choisir ce
que c'est que la peur est certainement
l'amour je suis né au maroc un pays
musulman dans les années 50 d'une maman
juive et d'un papa allemand qui lui
était dans l'armée française à ma
naissance
il a été porté disparu ma mère m'a donc
élever seule et pour toutes les raisons
qui étaient les siennes
elle a décidé de me baptisé catholique
malgré qu'elle eut été monoparentales
est analphabète
elle a choisi de faire des affaires dans
un monde d'hommes
bien avant le mouvement des femmes
plusieurs années après en janvier 90
j'ai choisi d'immigrer au canada et de
vivre au québec avec quatre enfants un
mari sans emploi est une maman malade
j'aurais pu trouver toutes les excuses
pour ne pas prendre ma vie en main
je les avais tout mais la vie elle a
choisi de m'apprendre une bonne leçon
que j'avais toujours le pouvoir de
choisir
j'ai été élevé avec l'amour d'une mère
exceptionnelle et d'un frère de 14 ans
mon aîné mais lorsque j'ai eu dix neuf
ans ils ont choisi pour toutes les
raisons qui étaient les leurs et qui
l'avait jugée bonne que je devais me
marier avec un homme que je n'avais pas
choisi je ne vous mentirai pas j'ai
pleuré j'ai mal hurler et j'ai frappé
dans le mur
puis j'ai eu peur mais j'ai quand même
réalisé que j'avais encore le choix que
j'avais le choix de m'enfuir et de
quitter ma famille ou celui de composer
avec la situation
peut-être peut-être que par ce que j'ai
vu ma mère se relever aussi souvent de
situations difficiles
je me suis dit c'est ma nouvelle réalité
alors j'en fais quoi par instinct de
survie par amour
j'ai trouvé la force de ne pas capituler
j'ai aimé mes enfants ma famille et même
cet homme mon mari que j'ai appris à
respecter
j'ai décidé non pas de choisir de
survivre mais de vivre
consciemment ou pas chacun d'entre nous
à un moment ou un autre de notre vie
nous avons perdu le pouvoir de choisir
lorsqu'on est jeune nos parents nos
enseignants et même la société nous
dicte la voie à suivre
celle qui est supposé nous apporter le
fameux bonheur de la maternelle aux
études universitaires
on nous apprend les réponses et qu'est
ce qu'on trouve agaçant les gens qui
posent des questions n'est ce pas et
pourquoi donc
parce qu'on veut nous faire rentrer dans
le moule la conformité elle elle est non
seulement valorisé mais elle est exigée
mais alors pourquoi est-on si
insatisfaits pourquoi y at-il autant de
gens malheureux malgré les belles
maisons malgré les bons emplois malgré
les bonnes voitures
pourquoi y at-il toujours ce petit
sentiment quelque part qui nous dit je
ne suis pas bien je ne suis pas
complètement heureux
est-ce que j'ai choisie par rapport aux
autres
ouais je choisis par rapport à mon ego
peut-être peut-être que je n'ai pas su
dire non ou que je n'ai pas osé
m'affirmer dire que ce n'est pas cette
vie là que je voulais mais on n'ose pas
bougé on est tout simplement paralysé
par la peur
mais la peur de quoi d'être rejetés de
se faire juger de se tromper de ne pas
faire partie du créa ou tout simplement
de ne pas être normal
pourtant pourtant tout le monde nous
donne des outils des livres des
conférences pour nous apprendre à
vaincre la peur alors pourquoi comme
vous comme vous je les ai lu ses livres
j'ai été écouté ses conférences mais
j'ai encore peur alors pourquoi ce
sentiment qui sort de mon ventre et qui
dit j'ai peur toujours car j'ai appris
que grâce à ces signaux
grâce aux signaux d'alarmé grâce à ces
coups de poing que je reçois dans le
ventre grâce à ces regards que j'ai eu à
jeter autour de moi à 360° complètement
habité par la peur j'ai compris que la
peur voulait m'envoyer simplement un
message
elle voulait simplement que je sois
attentif
elle voulait me dire que je venais de
comprendre que la seule façon que je me
recentre et que je vins ma peur c'était
de me recentrer sur mes pensées de me
recentrer sur mes actions et mes paroles
très jeune elle m'a appris à analyser la
nature humaine
elle m'a aidée à naviguer à travers les
différentes cultures et les différentes
personnalités
elle est donc devenue ma meilleure amie
elle est la clé de ma survie
mais au fond si on se posait vraiment la
question de quoi at-on peur on a tout
simplement peur de ne pas être aimée
l'humain lui a besoin d'être aimé et
d'être reconnus calculer et j'ai compris
à travers les épreuves que c'est l'amour
qui nous donne la force de reprendre le
pouvoir sur nos vies mais encore faut-il
apprendre à s'aimer soi même
il ya souvent dans notre vie une
personne qui nous livre ce message
fondamental dans mon cas ce fut ma mère
c'est peut-être votre père votre soeur
votre mère c'est peut-être vous même
j'ai appris à m'accepter avec mes
défauts
avec mes qualités avec mes folies avec
ma féminité et surtout avec ma
vulnérabilité
j'ai accepté que je ne pourrai jamais
plaire à tout le monde
j'ai compris que mes imperfections
étaient des forces et que mes échecs
étaient des bénédictions qui m'ont aidé
à grandir et à être en fait humaine dès
que je me suis acceptée
je me suis et mais pas de façon
prétentieusement de façon humble car
j'existe et je n'ai pas envie d'être qui
que ce soit d'autre que moi j'ai aussi
appris l'importance des mets et de
respecter les autres et de savoir
distinguer ce que l'on peut contrôler de
ce que l'on ne peut pas contrôler
je ne peux pas choisir pour les autres
je ne peux pas contrôler leur décision
mais je peux contrôler mes réactions
vous savez on a souvent des personnes
très inspirante qui gravitent autour de
nous on les aime tellement qu'on leur
cède le volant de notre vie chaque fois
chaque fois qu'on va décider de laisser
une autre personne interférer dans nos
décisions
on vient de céder la place du conducteur
lorsqu'on a un modèle on souhaite
limiter suivre son parcours on veut même
quelquefois devenir sa photocopie sans
le réaliser on vient de transférer son
pouvoir
bien sûr bien sûr qu'on peut admirer les
forces et les réalisations des autres
mais il faut surtout apprendre à les
adapter à nos réalités à nos valeurs à
nous et surtout à notre vie les réponses
que l'on trouve qu'on ne l'ont pas en se
trouvaient à l'extérieur et lyon les a
tous il suffit de vouloir s'écouter
en reprenant votre pouvoir vous ferez de
votre vie ce que vous voulez ce ne sera
pas facile
bien sûr que non on vit dans un monde
qui nous bombarde de mode d'emploi on en
trouve partout sur tous les sujets on
nous dit je vais vous apprendre à
éduquer vos enfants
même à embrasser votre partenaire et
surtout on veut nous apprendre à être
heureux passe mal ces recettes elles ne
sont pas ou du moins ses recettes
miracles elles se veulent juste
rassurante elle ne vous rendront pas
plus heureux car elles ne sont pas les
vôtres si vous décidez d'être unique
vous aller ramer à contre courant
vous allez trébuché et on voudra même
vous mettre à genoux mais quelle fierté
de se sentir authentique ne tolérerait
plus les excuses surtout pas celle
qu'ils viennent de vous comme mentor
comme entrepreneur je les ai presque
tout entendu on me dit souvent
vous savez madame untel j'aurais pu
réussir mais je n'ai pas eu de parents
riches
je n'ai pas la bonne couleur de peau ou
je n'ai pas de contacts dans mon milieu
chaque fois chaque fois que l'on se
cache derrière une excuse on vient de
transférer son pouvoir de choisir on se
déresponsabilise et on s'affaiblit
faites vous confiance si vous voulez
faire confiance aux autres respectez
vous si vous voulez respecter les autres
mais surtout surtout aimé vous si vous
voulez être capable d'aimer les autres
et d'être aimé en retour si certains
pourraient dire que je suis partie
perdante
mon instinct mon intuition m'a toujours
murmuré le contraire
l'impossible peut devenir possible car
mon histoire en est une preuve
vous avez le pouvoir de changer les
choses peu importe peu importe vos
bagages
peu importe la grandeur de vos rêves
mêmes même si vos elles ont été brisées
c'est à vous de choisir
est-ce que vous choisirez de survivre ou
choisirez-vous de vivre quel sera votre
choix